hello and welcome to this video playing
oops come on Grandmaster redkit who is
that no name but very high ratings okay
so let's see what we get yeah I'm trying
the Queen's Indian at the moment and see
what happens if they go Quincy to I
really don't have it would reply then
look at either i also don't know there
is stuff well but i want to experiment a
little bit yeah if they go bishops III I
now know that d 6 is a bad idea these
six seems to be a bad idea anyway what
else is there i can go with this okay
now i can take and play Bishop before
this is them normal and set up that
black is aiming for in this line the
non-id is c6 d5 and b5 and okay yeah
white wants to go 92 and possibly for so
let's see ya know I go go back here
funny enough okay cannot go here for at
the moment I think I'll going to be five
as planned threatening before winning a
piece but this will be certainly
addressed okay
hmm it doesn't look too bad huh okay
before it's not a good idea i guess
maybe just this and being ready to to
trade the bishop again yeah taking one
of three even giving giving giving this
up i don't know i don't like to play
with two nights against two bishops even
though the position would be reasonably
closed and static so that wasn't totally
off to take on a three but there's no
particular reason yet to do it I mean
something like 92 I just go back and
doesn't really nothing much has changed
okay probably wants to reroute this to
f4 f5 and b5 those porns they might be a
problem and not okay I could could
become become weak being attacked by
bishop on d2 and possibly later the
bishop from f1 mmm I'm not sure about
this pawn structure that should play
something like before at one moment if I
could be hard before later in the
endgame some bishops e7 could be the the
drawback and the problem I wonder hmm
before and the night to see three years
would be cool maybe I'm a let's go for
90 for him and before kind of unsure
what to do position is reasonably safe
but I don't really know all interesting
93's idea or f3 okay i'm doing this
being unsure if it's good or not we'll
see what happens i'm planning with this
square on c3m 94 93
Jim this is a move that I was thinking
about if it's any good i have e 5 but
here's God Bishop e3 and it's absolutely
not clear that this is helping me at all
I'll take lady 5b should be three and a
four this is a very hard to judge change
of structure I think I'll do it but I'm
not sure I'm not sure at all the pawn on
d4 is an annoyance for white but same
time I'm also making my bishop look a
little bit silly on a five okay and
where to go b6 orgy sex huh I go to g6
tough the same and then we'll come to a
4 mm maybe I should have gone to age 7
huh hmm yeah that would have been better
very likely
okay gioconda immediately obviously and
let's see my night he is not doing much
maybe I can get it to e6
gathered before a five set up at the end
map only five could become weak oh I
didn't see that one coming at all oh wow
that's bad that's bad
I didn't see it for coming let's read
that's really awful long time morning
it looks really awful
my bishop 187 double bed cot well it's
check check hey as a funny perpetual the
[ __ ] of course will not take as I'm
I'm still kind of holding on even though
it doesn't look good of course I don't
have king of eight or anything like that
I have no F novena so blue check yeah
this is the thing as I said at the end
is a 5-1 could have taken already no
diamonds Ox Bunyan basically black
resigns yeah f forum at the position was
completely fine up to here but that
position when f4 was coming that was a
big problem k Bishop g6 was already in
precise but when he had a force was bad
when I got to and when I allowed that i
think if i go to age seven this is not
so bad or maybe 36 I don't know this
should be kind of okay I don't think
that white has anything special here the
computer is on roughly equal but the
problem was when he got f4 in like this
an update here and this and now I have
to do something about it some some kind
of I have to play some kind of reaction
to that now the computer still thinks
I'm okay if I go h5 now well that's 20
III ah III I can play him bow oh that's
bad that I didn't see that move I have
to add just have to drop that porn
that's a fairly obvious strategic IDM
maybe to put the bishop you on that
square the point is not so important but
the bishop is active now computer
assesses this is equal as this is much
better than what I did a lot better so f
41 is that dangerous i just have to
react correctly
this is also an interesting movement to
this f5 no no I should play three this
is the thing I interesting really
interesting now I was I was a bit
shocked at f/4 was coming and reacted in
a passive way and I didn't think of e3
at all that's bad now thats bad this is
just a very bad decision now why does a
lot better he's got this space and then
I don't have four and now it's totally
one side look at this I just didn't have
the presence of mind to play three notes
but it's a lot better okay so it wasn't
that bad yeah the whole again before i
think i was i was quite comfortable i
think i like the position maybe I lost a
temple here and there but white also
moved around a lot without having a
particular idea so it didn't didn't
matter that much this is always
interesting do you want to do this or
not it wasn't necessary I mean I also
could have just stayed but it looked
interesting to put that pawn up to you
and it was okay i just have to i mean
okay bishop age 7 was more precise and i
had to see that he for most this is
really important yeah after that i'm in
a rotten and absolutely rotten position
now i don't think that check check he
allowed anything here I had the feeling
that he could punish it harder but maybe
it all was it was enough right I can
just sit there and can they can do
anything and at the end we knew all he
could have done that the whole time but
of course this is also a win so high III
heads a key move absolutely key move
okay very interesting thanks for
watching